hey everyone this is Steve with collider
we are here at Sundance in Park City and
uh I want to give a huge thank you to
our sponsor film EO because without film
EO we would not be here Sundance is
expensive to cover and they are allowing
us to support Indie movies and crazy
house you know what I mean um and I just
want to say that filo is shattering the
boundaries by of movie making by placing
the power to Greenlight films hands of
creators and fans uh and you can learn a
lot more about them by visiting their
website
film. I yes I do support our sponsors um
so listen I I want to start with um your
film is is uh pretty crazy I want to
start with that and I'm going to say I
love watching things where I really
don't know what the is going to
happen in the next scene so how have
actually you been describing this to
people um not not so because I I hate
bitching um so uh we wrote it and we had
a script and then we showed people no no
I meant like I'm so sorry I I the way I
said that was terrible um for people
that don't know anything about the movie
like the people watching yeah I'm so
sorry I the way that thing was people
don't know anything about the movie how
have you been describing it to like
friends and family I just keep it really
simple it's a 90 sitcom that really just
goes mental yeah that that's 100% true
it's like you threw a bomb on the set of
Full House
lit yeah literally yeah yeah they
literally did that
yeah I I the thing I've been wanting to
know is because this the film starts
like for no one's seen it yet but the
film starts like a sitcom but by the end
like and I'm not spoiling when I say
this like the sets get pretty messed
up yeah did you film this in order yes
we shot in sequence um and it was
because of that um because we built the
whole sitcom set um and yeah slowly it
gets destroyed um so it was really sad
when you know when the set was torn down
and it was uh it was like losing a house
it was really uh really hard for us
I I I definitely want to ask the cast
this like I'm sure you guys have read a
bunch of scripts what was it actually
like reading this script and how much
did like your agent or someone tell you
about it and how much were you
discovering on the page what the hell is
this movie and where is it
going well my agent called and said you
know you've got to read this script and
it's crazy I think he said it's
crazy and and you're going to love it
and so I read it really fast and then I
really enjoyed the script I mean you
just can't stop turning the page and you
have no idea what's going to happen and
it's just so weird and so interesting
and I loved the part and then I saw
their film flip and Stefan made a film
called wrong on the stunt man which I
thought was really good and his brother
is fantastic in it and um just really
interesting and so warped their brains I
love this there's this one part of that
movie where I this is my favorite part
but it's really bad but the guy he he
catches his wife having sex with some
stranger or some guy from the bar and
he's taking her a friend he's taking her
from behind and then he stops for a
second and then he just slowly continues
as he standing there has no respect for
him at all and that was very interesting
so like who are these people and then I
met them on a FaceTime and they were so
cute and so adorable and lovely and I
just wanted to come play with them so
here we are that is so not the answer I
expected in any way shape or form and I
love it I absolutely love it because
that's also so representative of this
film where you like I I watch a lot of
movies and I know you and I want to hear
your answers too but I watch a lot of
movies I truly didn't know what the next
scene was gonna be when I was watching
this which is great that was my fault
I'm very sorry um so for the two of you
what was it like reading the script and
your reaction to you know what I mean
yeah for I mean it's such a trip it's
such a cool trip and and knowing Stephan
and flips prior or work that they did
before this I had like I have a lot of
respect and like happiness for them
meaning like I just think they're the
they make is so cool so so I was
reading it with their with them in mind
and thinking whoa I don't get it I want
to do
it there were lots of questions huh yes
lots of question yeah but we discussed
right away we discussed and not
everything had an answer and it was fine
yeah yeah it was like so how yeah it's
just okay cool lot of exactly yeah but
does it have to make sense I
mean psychologically where no don't even
go there okay cool let's
go yeah I I remember reading it and then
not fully understanding it and then but
then I was like okay I'm just going to
prepare for the role itself and let the
script be whatever and then I came on
set and I started reading the like I had
to learn the lines you know and I and
then I figured out how actually how it
was the craziest thing I've ever shot I
think and oh I saw so many weird things
as well you so you see like grown people
doing so many weird things on a weird
movie like that grown people doing weird
you know what I mean like you don't see
stuff like that every day you never
actually no I I mean and also um uh what
I I don't this isn't a spoiler but like
I enjoyed seeing Nick Frost basically
covered in blood for like I don't know
how long but a lot of that movie he he
didn't what he didn't enjoy that oh I'm
sure he didn't cover blood no no that I
me he loved the idea of course but
practically oh it's terrible it's sticky
no no and and you have to be in it all
the time and then get it oh my God it's
a whole another thing but he didn't
complain once like he didn't complain
once oh come on that's not true not is
true at
all well I didn't hear it anyway we
always complain right I was going to be
like come on so fun yeah uh I am so
curious though from what you guys wrote
when you first writing this idea down
you do the script how much is it exactly
what you envisioned on screen and how
much changed along the way due to film
you know the that happens on set or
you couldn't do you know what I mean
like how Inception to finished product
um if you yeah I mean Inception
so when we start writing it sort of
evolves and escalates uh so it's not
like we have the complete thing in our
minds we just start the process and then
all ideas add up um and uh and Philip
and me really work like I mean together
we are like a different entity in in a
way I mean it's not a Stefan film it's
not a flip film it's really stepan and
flip film um so that's in the in in the
writing process but when we have the
script uh the finished script um that's
almost exactly like the finished product
um so and that's always with our things
because we yeah really want it a certain
way or we need it a certain way and um
and and it's and it's just we just make
what we love and um there's no
censorship or something like that so um
um but always when I mean you when you
have something in mind it is kind of
crazy but you get used to it of course
because yeah you're working on the
script and then you see it for the first
time in the scene with the actors then
you're like holy
this is what we wrote yeah ah okay
yeah this this is beautiful it's even
more than we sort of yeah envisioned in
a way um so yeah it was I mean that's
that's one of the most fun parts to see
the scenes or to hear the lines for the
first time uh with the actors um yeah
that's the extra layer that makes it
like yeah totally Bonkers I'm curious
for the cast uh you obviously you saw
the shooting schedule you know what you
had to do what was was the day that you
had circled in your brain in terms of I
cannot wait to film this or oh my effing
God I don't want to film this you know
what I mean maybe they would say blood
can we spoil or can we not spoil let's
not let's try to talk around the
spoilers oh but yeah you the wink that
happens to my character which is quite
obvious uh once you'll see the movie
you'll know what I mean I was like
what oh okay cool that's weird let's do
it you'll definitely know what when you
see the
movie yeah I don't know if I can say
with the all the you know oh yeah
it's it's going to be in the trailer I
guess all the amounts of drugs that I
had to do the am as the character that
that was really fun you have a very
special moment at the
end at at the end we're doing um when
the credits roll there's a very special
moment with his
character and that's where they drew a
line for us we were doing this improv
bit and we were we were all just doing
crazy things and assumed that everything
was on the up for grabs because given
the state of the film we just
made but apparently incest wasn't okay
so so he drew the
line in this in this movie
um in our story World mhm it didn't fit
didn't this was the Line in the Sand
this was the line this was it one of the
lines it was interesting that it was
found but um yeah thanks thanks for that
so let's talk also about the fact that
because this is a '90s sitcom it has a
theme song so let's talk about writing a
theme song or how did you discover this
you know figuring out what you
wanted um yeah it needed to be something
with the word crazy house in it um that
was and we of course were inspired by um
all the yeah Family Matters
cheers all the the Full House and with
the with the drums there's always these
these these special drums in there um so
um uh yeah our composer mikil marshman
uh just started to go for it uh it was
sort of a card Blan in a way I mean we
had these all these sitcom intros that
we send him like all right this is this
is the sound is the vibe and he he
totally yeah he totally nailed it um
first we had an electronic uh um version
that was just as a as a ref just for on
the set because we needed the song on
the set and then he started um getting
this uh sexh sexophone players um and
and and making it just really over the
top it's uh I literally thought you said
a sex phone me too that's what I heard
yeah good have yes yeah I it's
yeah I was trying to say sex sexophone
how do you say it how do you say that
saxophone
saxophone it's still sounds the same
sounds like sex sexy phone I like that
that's good so it's yeah it's really
sexy so I love throwing a curveball
sometimes during like uh uh an interview
and this is my curveball for you guys
you you've all done other projects
besides this one if someone has never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why crazy house crazy house tonight
because the premieres yeah it's the
last film it's it's it's it's our Magnus
Magnus Opus it's it's um yeah really
proud it's great everyone should see it
sure but like you've made other films I
made other films I know believe me I
know and so you know what I mean like
I'm I like it's like a way of of
mentioning something from your resume in
the
past don't all go at
once so crazy how minded okay
we we can move so great do do you have
something well I have something that I
really like that nobody saw so that
makes me sad
rein okay I mean some people saw it such
a little genre movie the the effects are
a little funny but it's it's such a good
movie otherwise that's but that's
actually what I like is that when people
can like mention something and if
someone's watching this interview they
might be like let me go check that out
yeah yes you know anyway I'll switch to
something else we should probably ask
our reps what do we all think that we
should
say
um so uh I'm working this in because
like I mentioned at the beginning uh
we're only here because of filo and so
um I want to read this because I think
it's a really great question uh filo is
all about putting the power to Green
Light films in the hands of creators and
to lean into that a little bit can each
of you name someone who empowered you on
a past project uh someone who believed
in you and uh put the creative power in
your hands when you didn't expect it and
it could have been on
this
good question yeah when yeah when when
you didn't expect it because I must say
that um you direct something you expect
to be in
power yes yes um but we got this trust
from uh our producer marw uh and he is
was always on our side so this is uh
flip and M our fifth film together um
and he was uh with all all of these
projects and he was always okay guys
just let's let's go all in it's it's
just it's your thing we're going to do
it um and he totally believed in us uh
always and it paid out uh so so it's a
yeah that is that's a great uh I'm
really thankful for that that's an
awesome way to work together so yeah
he's pretty important for sure
yeah anyone else so just wait sorry my
brain is working really slow like just
something some can you repeat the
question sure um can you name uh someone
who empowered you on a past project
someone who believed in you and put the
didn't expect it yeah yeah I have
someone Tim milons he cast me for py
blinders and it was a huge sleep for him
because that was a big show in England
and and I'm Dutch so he's the first one
who tried to do something English with
me and I'm very grateful for that
because that pushed me in a whole new
country Direction so he's cool I think
sounds cool he's really freaking
goal
uh uh I think Sophie Holland she a
casting director and she never actually
cast me in anything but she always
pushes me to the last few uh and then
someday I I'll get a part hopefully from
from that but she uh no I like her she
always keeps like pushing she has a lot
of love for me which is like oh okay
thank you you
know there you go that's
sure I think that there's been a lot of
those moments but the most recent one is
when bonio Del Toro wanted me
to be his wife in reptile and I didn't
see that coming you know we worked I I
hired him 27 years ago to be in excess
baggage with me and then he hired me
just recently to do this so it was a
real surprise and I just never even
occurred to me that we would work
together again uh I don't mean to dive
into this but I thought Grant did such a
great job with the material and I
thought you and bonio were fantastic
together
like I so believed in your relationship
thank you you know and if you haven't
seen reptile you know just throwing that
out there it streams on some Netflix
thing you know I I think people have
heard of it so um some people have it
yeah exactly I love talking about the
editing process because where it all
comes together so talk a little bit
about like editing this film and maybe
how it possibly changed in the editing
room or the way it tweaks how things can
change in the editing room or does it
not change with you guys at all yeah um
um there was I mean it's Nuance mostly
uh in the end so it's it's it's really I
mean yeah we in a way we're really
predictable we write something and then
we shoot it then we edit it like that
and um and because we do so much um
preparation U making the shot list and
uh knowing exactly what we need um it is
sort of exactly what we envisioned um
um and flip is the editor as well um so
um which makes it really easy for me
because if flip makes a cut it is
already like 99% of the film that it
should be um uh yeah and then it's and
then it's tweaking and and and and and
nuance and um and play yeah sometimes
play playing around with it but yeah it
was um yeah it was also pretty clear in
a way um boring no no it it makes
complete sense it's just fascinating
because there's no so many people I
speak to that can talk about the
dramatic changes that happened in the
editing room and sometimes it can be
exactly what they imagined you know and
um there's no um right or wrong you know
there's no in terms of the way it goes
real quick before we run out of time I
do have to ask you an individual
question I'm a big fan of Kyle Mooney
and I believe you did Y2K and I just
have to ask what was what can you tease
about the the project and what was it
like making it okay so I
Tim haaker and I play husband and wife
in this and he is so funny and um it was
just so much fun him and Kyle money have
a very interesting relationship on that
and Tim torments him and they they're
they're back and forth I just laughed
for all day long it was really fun you
paid to be there I paid to be there it
was easy it was easy um and everyone in
it is so lovely and but mostly my stuff
was with Tim and Kyle was there just he
he plays he does they do a bit of it on
something online bless you where it's
sort of like Tim's abusing him and Kyle
takes it and this is this skit they're
constantly doing of him being abused and
it's so funny so anyway the behind the
scenes were real fun I'm a big fan um
real last thing uh is the film for sale
here crazy house or is it it is yeah so
um if you're interested right I do not I
do not have the uh my bank account can't
support that but I do yeah but I do
really hope that it sells quick and that
people can see it and I really want to
give a huge thank you to you guys for
coming in and again a huge thank you to
film EO for being our sponsor you can
watch a lot more Sundance interviews on
collider thank you so much you guys have
a great Fest thanks thanks for having us
good see
you